John is with us in York Pennsylvania hey
John welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I
did hey what's up I have a question
about my car policy with work or my car
allowance rather if my car is a specific
color I get a higher car allowance call
I don't want to sell mine
yes the color of my car company company
policy must be the company color it's
one of the company colors yes but it's
not like some random color the colors
actually white my car is currently like
a metallic black and I know I've
listened to you for a little while now
and I've heard you say you don't put
money into things that go down and value
but so what I've been considering doing
is wrapping my vehicle with like a vinyl
and that would increase my car allowance
each month it would take me roughly ten
months that additional allowance to make
back what it costs me to wrap the
vehicle okay so how much is your car
allowance now and how much does it go up
if it's white it's about 350 months now
and it goes up about $300 extra if it's
white you get 650 versus 350 correct
what is their motivation for that I'm
obviously not quite sure but I gotta
know that's the company I can't say over
the radio okay all right so it's a major
national company no it's actually not
it's it's it's in it's in Baltimore
Maryland that's you know it's a local
company okay yeah so far that's just
that's wild all right okay so what's
your car worth my car well so I that's a
loaded question but I'll give you the
quick story is that I purchased a car
and didn't realize that it was a buy
back so when I went to trade it in a
while ago I couldn't get what was what
it was worth so the dealer one to give
me like 20 not even $20,000 is really
worth closer to 32,000 so I don't want
to sell it and only
different car you want to rap out and it
costs like it cost like three grand to
rap it correct and for me we have the my
wife when I have the cash to do it if we
need to
you have any debt wouldn't be just just
this car yet I still owe twenty twenty
thousand dollars on this car rally and
do you drum up a lot for work I do I
Drive I Drive about an hour every day
back and forth two hours total Wow
but that's not that's a commute correct
Wow okay but some but you're not like on
the road for work not not a whole lot
just a little bit okay mmm what's your
household income we're about 165 run way
okay
yeah I mean yeah it makes sense you'll
get your money back in ten months it's a
break even if you get fired inside of
ten months you lose money on us on this
but it sounds like you feel like the
jobs pretty stable and so if you do and
you don't mind driving a car that is
wrapped and of course you can unwrap it
and clean it easily when you get
registered on it and I'm told the rap
lasts roughly 7 years so it you know it
looks like any other regular painted car
apparently so yeah if it's done right it
can it can it's it's almost like a skin
kind of protects the pain actually why
that's why I thought it'd be a great
question for you it's it's different
that's for sure so yeah I believe I
wouldn't do that pay cash for it
certainly we're not gonna do anything
with that and then take your wonderful
income and get the stupid car paid off
as soon as possible if you're going to
drive it because you're obviously
putting a lot of miles on it just with
your commute if nothing else but yeah
sure they're willing to over they're
willing to double your car allowance
almost wow that's amazing